Ryan Reynolds shuts down rumors of  turmoil with wife Blake Lively the 41  year old actor took to social media on  Saturday to hilariously clap back at  reports he and his 30 year old wife are  struggling to spend quality time  together jokingly quote tweeting I wish  I could use a little me time Ryan and  Blake share two daughters together  three-year-old James and one-year-old in  Eze and have been married for over five  years and a week before the rumours  began the busy parents proved their  total relationship goals while cozying  up on the red carpet at the New York  City premiere a final portrait their  first since the October screening of  Blake's film all I see is you  spectacular  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]